there's a community that is fully
furious with you in a smaller community
that believes in you why did you decide
one day to wake up and piss off
everybody well I didn't really decide
that at all if you are snotty Nakamura
you're essentially worth eight point
eight million dollars it matters not how
much money you have you make something
but building creating investing I want
you to use Bitcoin and I want you to
hoard it but why were you not public
from day one cash is disappearing that's
a bad thing
so if I wanted to go into Apple Walmart
Amazon
I can't make any to purchase with
Bitcoin today no and that's a problem
why don't you sell all your Bitcoin if
you try and move a hundred million
dollars the value of bitcoins going to
go right now let's just say somebody
really pissed you off
can you bring down the whole concept of
Bitcoin if you wanted to what is the
concept of Bitcoin by this you'll be
rich they're allowing child pornography
or allowing money launderers bitcoin was
never designed to be any of those things
do you regret creating Bitcoin I was
building a working version of electronic
cash everyone you'll be able to scam is
right here Bitcoin look what I've done
I've helped by clicking like you haven't
and all these people who think they have
you're scum and you don't like that get
up your frickin ass and do something
about it my guest today is Craig Wright
who claims to be Satoshi Nakamoto which
some of you agree with some of you don't
and he's done a lot of things in his
career a lot of interesting things in
his career and after the recent
interview with Max Keiser our guy Allen
reached out and said maybe we ought to
have Craig Wright as a guest and he
agreed so Craig thank you so much for
being a guest on my team you're welcome
so how much how much you know I call
people I'm not in the Bitcoin world
obviously I have owned Bitcoin at a
small percentage of Bitcoin but I'm not
one that follows all the forms I'm not
one that's you know the community is an
interesting community of a lot of true
believers there's a community that is
fully furious with you in a smaller
community that believes in you why did
you decide one day to wake up and piss
off everybody
well I didn't really decide that at all
I mean where people are going wrong is
that they seem to think that I'm going
to invent a creation and then be happy
that everyone twists and makes it into
something else
shortly after I left sort of my
pseudonym with the sort of launch of
drug markets and whatever else that I
didn't really want we had people like
the Electronic Frontier Foundation come
out with these comments about Bitcoin
this new censorship resistance system
talking about how it will stop
government's taking your money and all
the stuff Bitcoin doesn't do anything
like that that is all mythology and so
these people hate me for the simple fact
that I'm ruining their myth it's
basically the case of they've produced a
Church of Satoshi and I've come back and
I'm not what they want it's the scene in
dusky esky where the Christ comes back
to actually talk with the Inquisitor and
the Inquisitor doesn't want him he sits
there saying we don't need you anymore
the church is fine but the church is not
fine and these people that what they're
wanting to do is not find bitcoins
designed to be a system that is open and
honest you can't do that by destroying
government's people forget that
government is just a word what
government is at the end of the day
whether it's good or bad it's people so
if we have a good government it's
because we have a system that is managed
and controlled by people that care about
it and if we have a bad government it's
because people allow them to have that
okay so for the average person you just
went to a crazy different place today
you went to a very deep place but for
the for the average let me just put some
things out there numbers wise if you are
Sochi Nakamoto if you're Satoshi
Nakamoto if you are and when I say if
you are you're saying you know you are
I'm just
for the skeptics if you are saturated oh
you're essentially worth on paper eight
point eight million dollars is that
pretty accurate I don't actually know I
know it's a lot of money I don't sit
there watch in the price yes it's a lot
of money so that's that's a lot of money
eight point eight billion and I know at
the peak of it one Bitcoin to twenty
thousand dollars it was around twenty
billion dollars of the reality there
though is you can't actually sell any of
these things for that amount so and
people say you've got that much money
but you don't really because if you try
and sell it then it goes down a lot so
the actual realizable value is a lot
less than that but the reality here is
it matters not about how much money you
have it matters what you what you can do
what you can actually live in your life
and I have enough money to go through
university myself still to pay for my
kids to go through university to have
them educated properly to travel to
spend time with my family to do things I
want to what more is really important I
mean past that who cares yeah I know but
but the thing is like you know if you
look at a theory and founder of vitaliy
he's a pretty public guy it's not like
he is hidden you know this is why i'm
i'm the founder and he does whatever he
can to not be that much of a guy that's
the control because the whole thing
about a crypto is the fact that it's the
complete opposite of banking so it's no
one figure you look at it's not a
hierarchy type of a model but that's
actually wrong so this is this is part
of what they don't like there are no
sort of oh we're we're out of this the
telic is the leader he is the issue of
aetherium when he decided that the doubt
didn't work he changed it it wasn't a
community or a group none of this is
about distributed groups to it that's a
lie that's propagated and promoted so
that these few people in charge can say
don't look at me don't take me to be
responsible I didn't do that that's the
whole point it is these people who are
shirking their responsibility
who are basically allowing all sorts of
heinous things to be just rife and the
truth of the matter is they're making
money out of that they're allowing child
porn they're allowing drug sales hard
drugs and they're sitting there going
it's not my fault the community wants it
the community doesn't vote on this
the consensus mechanism in Bitcoin is
the creation of blocks and present in
BTC well even there are only 32 nodes of
that three or four control the whole
system now the developer bit they said
they're going the community does this
the community don't do anything three
people control the github keys anythi
reham two people basically do it I mean
your average company like General Motors
has more distant realization than any
cryptocurrency that people are talking
about this this whole nature of it's
about decentralization was never about
Bitcoin it's people who piled in after I
left the scene in 2011 we've taken up
this concept and run round going
bitcoins broken we have to fix it but
God was never designed to be any of
those things but Kuhn was it's okay so
when you're saying down you're saying
but Alec he's saying I'm just trying to
get people to do what they want to do
I'm not like the bank leader I'm not the
hierarchy leader you're saying a
complete opposite so what does that make
you if you're saying you are Satoshi
Nakamoto I'm saying exactly the same
things I said online I never said that
this was a decentralized system or that
it's good for drug sales or any of these
things I actually said don't invite
WikiLeaks and yet that's the opposite of
what everyone did I didn't run round
going it's an anti banking system
there's no quote she'll find for me at
any point saying those things I didn't
say it replaces banking and that's
really ignorant when you think about it
banking is not cash
bitcoin is an electronic cash system now
banking on the other hand is
distribution of capital Bitcoin doesn't
take your funds and pool them and give
out home loans it doesn't give out
business loans
it doesn't manage those sources of funds
its cash and this is these people are
too ignorant to even realize or if
they're not ignorant they're
disingenuous and they're sitting there
saying that we're going to replace
banking for third-world people it's not
third well people don't have investment
they don't have loans saying you've got
Bitcoin isn't going to pull those people
out of poverty what it does is it allows
this false narrative of a Ponzi where
people sit there going it's gonna keep
going up forever invest now because I've
already invested and I want more money
that's the problem here so so many
people are building so do you feel it
sounds like you're you're you don't
sound optimistic you sound pessimistic
so let's just say you are the founder of
Bitcoin and you're the monkey or Satoshi
Nakamoto if you are do you regret
creating Bitcoin no I regret not
managing things properly I noticed
you've got a cross around your neck and
I used to be a pastor and I've actually
a thousand random Catholic and moved
over to be Protestant because it fit me
better and I like actually being married
but there's a concept of stewardship so
the whole Catholic ideal of stewardship
is important whether you're Protestant
or Catholic or whatever else this idea
of having long-term investment ownership
and managing everything knowing your
problems being responsible this is what
really built Western culture
responsibility knowing that you are the
center of your own problem
and causes and what I regret is when I
left when I sort of left everything
happened the way it was I thought I
could work in the background and fix
things without being involved but I
abdicated not sort of delegated there's
a big difference and part of stewardship
is taking ownership for what you do
cause your problems and everything like
that and that's what I regret I regret
not doing that not sort of it was a
harder choice
and I should have made it back then so
what if you're saying
vitaliy gets bumped again he's the
leader of material but why were you not
public from day one I thought things
would sort themselves out I didn't I
mean there was a church of satoshi for a
while there was a whole lot of other
thing I mean I did not foresee any of
this the whole idea of Bitcoin and the
protocol is that it doesn't change
none of this we get to keep doing soft
Forks or hard Forks or anything the
whole concept of set and stone is we
have a protocol that grows and miners
don't vote as everyone says miners don't
choose what the protocol is think about
that for a moment that is a horrible
scenario that is might makes right those
were the most money the most power get
to choose what happens in our monetary
system that's not democratic that's not
fair do you really want to see some
large Russian company or rut large
Chinese company dictating world
financial policy that's what these
people are arguing that criminals can
dictate financial policy that can't be
changed even by government or law
enforcement really think about that for
a moment we get to large miners each
with 30% and they have joint controllers
in oligarchy and they can dictate to the
rest of the world that child pornography
is good
Antonopoulos writer of mastering [ __ ]
coin came up with this oh well it's not
my place to tell people that child pawns
bag I mean if people want to do that
they should make their own decisions
wrong I don't care about this for curly
in postmodern ideal I still believe that
we have sort of an overarching idea of
morality this pure pluralist system
Hegelian horrible world of everyone
having a right to whatever they believe
no matter how low and despicable it is
is wrong I don't really care there is a
morality that is native to humanity and
doing the wrong things will never be
acceptable and allowing a small cadre of
potentially criminals who are money
launderers and want to take money and do
all these things that have already
mentioned and get away with it because
they have more hash power that is
asinine so what kind of people has
Bitcoin attracted you mentioned child
porn out twice a drug traffic what kind
of people have been turned on by Bitcoin
because they can go naughty they can
break the law and not be found what kind
of community has that attracted in
around June July 2010 there was the
first inkling of this which I didn't
take too seriously at the time the first
version of what became Silk Road was
launched initially selling things like
magic mushrooms and whatever else and
then it broke out into straight into
heroin I mean it's one thing if you want
to try and allow people to sell pot
especially where it's legal but they
can't get banking it's another to start
saying that well heroines ok - it's
personal choice it's not it's incredibly
addictive and destructive the same with
meth and ice and all these other things
and a lot of people came as
eegh old collapsed eagled was taken down
around the start of bitcoin and then at
the end of that period Liberty Reserve
with Liberty Reserve euro and Liberty
Reserve dollar was also taken down and
all of those people flocked into Bitcoin
because the Electronic Frontier
Foundation WikiLeaks other people were
sitting there going bitcoins this system
that you can't track can't trace that
allows you to do anything we've now seen
some of the largest child pornography
rings in the world taken down because
people attract Bitcoin transactions in
and out of them there are only just
recently a couple of those one in Korea
just a little while ago
they've been many drug sites taken down
but the whole thing here is Bitcoin
isn't encrypted it's not really a
cryptocurrency there's no encryption at
all the Bitcoin it's an open ledger the
identity function is firewalled so if
you can imagine this the way it's
written is like having an index that
index links the individual who owns the
tokens but simultaneously it allows
other people not to see who that is so
the way to think about this is tsunami
means that you can externally link
information without actually making it
all public so it doesn't mean you don't
have identity in fact digital signatures
require identity the definition of a
signature means that you can't be
anonymous so all these people saying
there's digital signatures and Bitcoin
only if you have identity if it's
anonymous it's not a signature so if we
take that a little bit further we start
thinking about the fact that we have
this record and it's designed to be
something like an old bugger like me
would understand I've worked in
accounting firms and in the past we used
to have paper backed sort of records
Ledger's journals and they're really
difficult to change they're expensive to
try and change so if you have all that
you can't just scribble out
entry and added because everything needs
to sort of follow and be correct write
down a double entry journal so you can't
go somewhere in the past and scribble
out online but you can fix it because it
is visible because everyone can read it
think about this you have all these
immutable journals in the past but
people made mistakes so they still have
errata sheets they still have linked
journals where they can change things
none of this having to go back and
recalculate all the hashes or any of
this stuff all you need to do is have
the miners say this is what the new
entry is and they can do that following
a court order or whatever else purpose
of nodes is not to have this
decentralized finance idea which
actually goes right back to the 1920s
there the the original sort of concept
of having promotion of shares and
plugging shares and everything like that
that led to the 1929 crash that was
really about the term democratizing
finance there were people like they are
with Bitcoin right now sitting there
going buy this you'll be rich you don't
need to understand it you don't need to
comprehend it just buy it sit on it
you'll be rich that was the promise then
that's the promise now it's a lot of
these people so I'm very positive with
Bitcoin just not what people say is
Bitcoin so if you were to sell me
bitcoins because that's how it's being
sold it's an investment put your money
in D you're gonna be rich it's gonna go
to a hundred thousand it's gonna go to a
million dollars you know it's gonna go
to that how would you sell me what
bitcoin is explained to me here's what
bitcoin is not that what would it be
I wouldn't I wouldn't create plumbing
when a normal person buys a house unless
they're a little bit the sort of
perfectionist I'll say the nice way
pedantic on certain things then they're
not going to sit there going well I need
this particular plumbing in this part of
the house and these faucets and I need
ceramic here and I need copper there and
now the truth of the matter is you don't
care about how your internet connection
basically sends packets you shouldn't
care about how your money does it either
I don't want people sitting there and
going that there's some super wizard and
no they say I just want it to be secure
plumbing I want it to sit there in the
background so that accountants and fraud
analysts can review things and know that
it's secure I want it so that it's fast
it's better than Visa that it cost lists
and PayPal that people can hold their
own cash again which cash is
disappearing that's a bad thing I want
you to use Bitcoin I know what you do
hoard it the whole concept of having
hoarded money is a pathology it's wrong
if you want to save good if you want to
build good if you want to create
something but this pathology about I'm
gonna get a lump of gold and hope that
it goes up in value is wrong how about
actually taking something and building
with it if we think about going into the
old parables the the parable of the
servant and I'm gonna throw this one in
there the man who had his three servants
and he gives each of them some money and
one of them buries it under a rock well
he still has it at the end but the one
who's spent it and did something and
planted crops and and wet I mean that's
really what it's about you don't make
anything from having a lump of money
sitting there you make something but
building things using money is what
matters
creating investing so based on what
you're saying is Bitcoin is not a method
of investment Bitcoin was built to use
to used meaning to purchase things
that's cheaper than PayPal not
necessarily as a method of let me buy a
bunch let it sit and in five ten years
later I sell it for more make more money
exactly it's really about having a
system that allows us to have micro
payments more than anything else so the
Internet has been crying out for micro
payments for years a decade ago when I
launched Bitcoin people everyone wanted
to solve micro payments Facebook our on
Facebook coin version six now everyone's
going Libre oh whatever else except this
is version six it has failed five times
already
Amazon coin failed they've all done
these things and they keep trying
because it is valuable to get digital
money that can be sold in fractions of a
cent if you've got fees that are a
dollar or even 20 cents it doesn't work
you need fees of a tenth of a hundredth
of a thousandth of a centers at scales
not this whole concept of we're going to
take down the government and replace it
with what it's a concept of how do we no
longer have advertising and hate speech
rule the internet how do we move Twitter
away from basically incentivizing people
from fighting how do we disincentivize
terrorist groups from using these things
to find people who they can basically
convert if we don't have people sold if
we don't have their lives as part of
this sort of I guess
well track where you are monitor what
you do culture that Google and Facebook
have created then we have a different
internet what do you mean what you just
went to Twitter Facebook I know you're
not a big fan of social media and by the
way for full disclosure for people to
know this you got a degree in theology
you you study theology coming up right I
mean that was one of the things you
studied coming up in college yeah and
and and it seems like you have a
challenge with Twitter because of what
you just said right now with you know
the way they make their money is pinning
people against each other and aversive I
heard you say something about the fact
that there is a problem with Twitter
Facebook all these things being cheap
and being free it shouldn't be free
because if it is free you can use bots
to create imaginary issues what were you
going with no the problem is it isn't
free they are divisive they are many
other things because they're not free
people think that they're free they
don't see the cost but whenever you have
this free ment sort of mantra it is in
reality anything but free we have a
system that sells you you put in your
information you put in your photos and
they own it all they get to use it all
they get copyright over what you're
doing they get access to all you're
saying they get to sell your information
basically do either governments or
businesses or whatever also people can
find out where you go what you do and
then they can do that to promote
advertising and sales and whatever else
and things you don't need or want and
ideas that really shouldn't be there
yeah why because Twitter makes a few
cents every time so rather than having
knowledge of what things actually cost
we have a hidden cost now the sec back
in 1999 actually took action against a
number of decentralized companies who
were saying that they were giving out
shares and saying that they're not
covered because well that new technology
they can
do web IPOs which is the modern word so
is called an ICO and they were issuing
shares if people signed up on their site
so you put in your your name address and
some personal information and they gave
you shares and guess what every time you
put a mere email address back in 1999
when there weren't that many email
addresses when advertising wasn't that
big the sec analyzed that and still came
up back then with your information was
worth eleven dollars just by doing that
little bit so right now we are in a
world where we have much more
information where the richness of
information about your life if you have
facebook on your phone is incredibly
deep and now we're selling all that
information and there's not eleven
dollars anymore it's not cheap now
facebook couldn't make money without
doing all this imagine if every day they
got half a cent from you they'd still be
profitable imagine half a cent from all
their people they'd be very profitable
that people can even have blog posts and
whatever else that they sell other
things that they do online and they can
make money without having to have bank
accounts set up all sorts of things yet
that's not what we're doing because
he'll billions of dollars of advertising
most of which is not really what anyone
ever wants if Facebook got a half a cent
every day from every user at 2.2 billion
that's some 330 million a month times 12
is not a lot of money it's four billion
a year they wouldn't be as profitable as
they are today not the negative the
negative how much do they get right now
not in revenue but in profit in Salah
more than four billion it's a lot more
than four billion I mean I know he lost
money seven billion last week but the
only reason I'm asking this is because
I'm business model now you made me know
it's a smarter which is a complete
different topic can a business model of
charging me every day a certain amount
really work for others to get and will
it can it scale to 2.2 billion I don't
know can scale to 2.2 billion users on
on Facebook going back to going back to
a crypto let's let's stay on that topic
for a second because I wanted to follow
up with this year for folks who know
Bitcoin and here's what I've learned
from a lot of people that claim they
know Bitcoin 99% of Bitcoin folks have
no clue how this thing works would you
agree with that that majority but don't
really know everything about Bitcoin I
even take it further make it know you
something about bit going in who's
involved in it maybe 1 in 10,000 ok even
better I mean I agree with you because
it's so complex and people try to sound
like they're experts and they know what
they're doing but it's a very technical
issue to make it comparable to another
thing I'll ask you and maybe you can
help me out with this is would you be
considered if someone if you are subtly
Nakamoto are you comparable to a founder
of a company to a fund manager to
somebody who just happened to find gold
mine who would that be comparable to if
you were to compare the founder to
something what would that be I'm an
issue uh contrary to what people say
whenever you create something like
Bitcoin core created something
Vitalik created something and everyone
runs around going there's no issuing no
there is I assured Bitcoin with all the
requirements for sort of what that means
and all the rest and vitalik issued
aetherium and the people in Bitcoin core
issued BTC and other derivatives so the
end of the day everyone's running around
law card touches and course it can't
it's just slow so what I can
myself I would say an inventor we've got
now 1080 patents around 400 Payton
families filed we have over a thousand
in the backlog for white papers
internally a ten chain by the time I
finish with what we've already got
there'll be at least six thousand so oh
it's a minute so if you're an issuer can
you can you also if you really want it
if somebody really pissed you off let's
just say somebody really pissed you off
can you bring down the whole concept of
Bitcoin if you wanted to what is the
concept of Bitcoin before I can answer
that one I'll need to know what the
concept is that I'm bringing now I mean
I'm talking about all of these folks
that have money in Bitcoin that about
Bitcoin Bitcoin can you essentially make
Bitcoin go away where it's non-existent
where everybody loses all the value to
have a Bitcoin well that depends on what
you're considering so if you're looking
at BTC then that's already on shaky
ground long term there's only going to
be one system contrary to what people
say with this whole everyone will have
their own money and whatever else no
there won't be it's like how many
different types of internet do you have
I mean the reality is we're not going to
be on 50 different networks back thirty
years ago we had decnet up and ARPANET
which became in today we had vanian
bynes net buoy
Novell NetWare IPX I have many many
different network protocols the benefit
in any system that is networked is
connectivity between all the interacting
players and there are still some decnet
networks there are still some Mannion
behind networks globally
they're very small and they're legacy
and people can't get rid of them but the
reality is no one
about them and that's where we're going
to be bitcoins going to be something it
can't be a promise of a promise so right
now you have people saying it's going to
be valuable because it's going to be
more valuable that doesn't work if you
want Bitcoin to be valuable it has to be
because it's used not a promise that in
the future will solve things but because
it's used
not because it's decentralized I mean
what does that really even mean
I mean think about it there's a where
decentralized but and what what do you
mean by decentralized not that we have
everyone voting because you know did
that a Bitcoin contrary to the lies
people tell you about how everyone gets
to say bull
everyone doesn't get a say BTC world
there are three developers who basically
sit there and choose what happens and in
a manner analogous to Stalin they sit
there and go you can vote for me I will
do everything I promised to do unless
they don't and if you don't like it you
can vote for me again how much power and
control does do three have though if
they lose it they three they're furious
that upset with everybody what's the
worst thing they can do whatever they
want which is prank the network because
so you could essentially break the
network if you wanted to the only
control here is legal so this whole
anarchist anti-government bit doesn't
work the reason you can't is because
it's really a unilateral contract it's
the same as if I put contract like
little stickers up saying lost dog I'll
pay you 50 pounds if you find my dog now
the contract happens when someone
decides to look for the dog and if they
find the dog they're owed 50 pounds but
if they don't find the dog I don't owe
them anything and that's the same thing
in Bitcoin so
the developers have a unilateral
contract a promise to the miners in the
community that they have to maintain and
right now they change it all the time so
the only real protection is the fact
that someone can sue them someone can
actually hold them to account and a
court can actually tell you know you
have you can't do that the same way
Microsoft have been forced to change
code Google have been forced to change
code Amazon Facebook all these companies
even small companies get forced by
courts to change code all the time and
sitting there going you can't make us do
well of course you can make them do
really I mean what a stupid statement
saying you can't stop us
well course you can where where do you
think you're going to put your code
where do you think you're going to put
your servers this concept we can just
change the code and have new sort of
systems and the hash rate we can move
really and what then a new commercial
entity will come in and have their
equipment seized exchangers need to
access banking
right now they can be cut off globally I
mean I used to do a lot of work in the
gaming industry gambling and I helped
set up
Lassiter's casino and I helped other
ones licensed ones there's a difference
and banking is important you can be
basically cut off at the knees instantly
if a government decides they're not
going to renew your banking license or
your exchange license or whatever else
so this we can do whatever it's a myth a
myth to sell something so that they can
promote value that doesn't exist
it isn't about we're going to have
billions of transactions and everyone
will actually be able to sell things
online it is no longer any of these
promises that everyone said about global
money money needs to be used money isn't
just a store of value store values a
secondary part of money and it doesn't
even mean what these people are saying
store of value means it stays the same
value the ideal value you store in the
u.s. is the US dollar for stop because
by definition a store of value in
economics means something that a year
later from now you will pay that with a
contract at the same rate it will be
worth the same not more not less if it
is worth a cent more it is less of a
unit of value than if it was the same
thing if it's worth a cent less the same
the ideals
our value is a dollar when you're in
America the arrow people are making is
thinking that it's about investment
value store value by definition isn't
anything to do with investment it's to
do with stability so what would
percentage of Bitcoin right now is being
used to purchase items oh very very
small there was more monetary value of
Bitcoin spent in 2011 than there is now
what's causing that
this mantra of gambling that bitcoins a
way of making money without tax that
whatever else I think majority of sort
of sales are on to exchanges for people
wanting to make money without being
taxed and things like this and which is
really stupid because they're going to
find out that they have no money
the requirements are already in place
the laws are already in place it takes
time to kick in so in 18 months from now
the provisions in money laundering
directive number five that hits Europe
and Britain and it will be a criminal
act to have wallets that don't link to
identity and hold more than a hundred
and fifty euros worth of value there's
not much money Craig let me ask you the
right now bitcoin as of right now I just
ran to this 9,000 226 okay right now
it's Bitcoin more likely to go to
$100,000 or more likely go to $100
BTC is not going to get $100,000
. it's not going to go to $100,000 no if
you're somebody that's an analyst and
you're making a prediction are you
saying higher or lower lower how much
lower in time a lot the problem is
people don't realize people forget so go
back 20 years
we had digital money we had industries
doing this bigger than now sir
we had eagled m-net : appear things that
were having people invest money into
Ponzi's once again and with the stock
market crash and all the rest they went
basically bust they all disappeared so
just believing things will go up because
they'll go up
doesn't work this is dog food calm if
you don't have something here that
actually makes money that actually does
the work that is an empty promise
eventually it ends
it means Amazon not dog food calm if you
don't have a system that transfers more
volume every day at a lower rate more
efficiently more effectively than say
here Visa and MasterCard and all these
other things if they're not using your
system as a transmission system then
eventually someone's going to replace
you certainly they're going bitcoin no
sorry
you either build something better or
else that's just the way the world works
you may not like it doesn't matter this
is how it is people are fickle we want
to see you doing things we want to see
you build things in this concept that
there are everyone who will ever get
into Bitcoin based on a store a value
that goes up on a price the Ponzi scam
they're here they're no more they're
gone that's it the hole everyone you'll
be able to scam is right here in Bitcoin
the rest of the people out there don't
care the rest of the people will care
when this is digital cash not that they
make money on that they use until that
happens it's not happening
a pretty bold prediction right there to
say you are saturated and it's 9,000 to
26 and it's got more likelihood of going
$200 and it does $2,000 I don't consider
BTC Bitcoin I mean there's no sacred in
Bitcoin the concept of what they're
selling is not what I created so by the
way how did it become a religion how did
it become such a attractive cult-like
following type of a person because
typically in order for something to have
a cult-like following there must be a
founder that has a cult-like following
of a spirit aka Steve Jobs you know a
person who has that aura and that
feeling and we gonna take over the world
how did this become then without
somebody that was a prophet claiming
what this is going to replace in my
absence people created a mythology
unfortunately that's what happened
so people sit there saying this is what
I meant no what I meant was fairly clear
when I argued with people and I said
bitcoin ends and data centers I meant
bitcoin ends in data centers full stop
I did not mean that everyone sits there
at home going we're going to sell blocks
for the sake of it it's not designed for
that the truth of the matter is that
that's what people don't want to hear
they these people in the whole little
cultish version of Bitcoin don't want me
to sit there and say the reason for
proof of work and bitcoin is purely and
simply to make sure nodes cannot ever be
anonymous the 2016 block sort of
difficulty adjustment period is so that
they can never be more than 2,000 nodes
and in reality because you have a
power-law distribution of investment you
never have more than 100 right now we
have 32 from 2011 till now every single
node is known and we had
ninety-eight in that entire period nine
years 98 nodes and it's very simple to
tell whether you're a node have you
created a block full stop you say for
this thing to work it's got a people
people got to spend a Bitcoin and
purchase things and yeah but not a lot
of it is being spent it's a fair to say
it's less than 1% of bitcoins being used
to purchase items is that a fair
assessment and it's a fair assessment
yes okay so if if you have the monkey or
Satoshi Nakamoto and that as of today
give or take is worth eight point eight
billion dollars how come you're not
spending that money purchasing items so
it's you know moving how come you're not
doing it well first of all I do second
you can't actually spend that much money
in Bitcoin in derivatives like BTC the
liquidity is not there you can't go out
there and spend a billion dollars . so
if you try and move a hundred million
dollars the value of bitcoins going to
go right now so there isn't eight
billion dollars there that's just an
arbitrary sort of artificial thing that
people say the reality is if even
without people knowing it was me if
there's a way of doing it if I could try
and spend everything there might be
fifty million dollars out of this by the
time if I tried to dump it all at once
most if I still could I have a time I
might be able to get five times that and
have two hundred and fifty that would be
it
what's the biggest purchase you made
with a Bitcoin paid for a number of
things a pet I've had a rather
extravagant holiday I've got a little
bit of art work most of my stuff that is
boring my university fees are probably
my biggest expense every year is it but
an amount if you were to even if you
don't disclose what it is what is the
amount that was the biggest purchase you
were able to make with Bitcoin oh the
purchase biggest purchase I'd say would
be 50 grand 50 dude do we know what is
the biggest purchase ever made with
Bitcoin or no is that public info now
it's not really public now so no one
would know what kind of a purchase has
been made that's the biggest purchase
with Bitcoin well not no one would know
but it's not public this is the whole
thing the ledger doesn't say who said
what and who got what and where it went
so there's a ledger information there
but that then a lot ends with
individuals and what they have so what
who's been the biggest most credible
source of investor that bought the
biggest amount of Bitcoin is that public
in for now there are a number of those
but I don't know what the biggest would
be I mean I wouldn't say investor anyway
I'd say mostly gamblers investor don't
know sorry his Peter Thiel one of the
bigger proponents of Bitcoin would you
say he's one of them I'd be surprised if
he is you'd be surprised if he is is
there a well-known person that's an
analyst hedge fund somebody that came
out and said we're gonna go buy this
much Bitcoin you're talking to the wrong
person on that sorry
interesting interesting that why
wouldn't you know that do that that
doesn't interest you at all with how
investors in analysts look at the
Bitcoin not really I don't see them as
investors I see them as gamblers so I'm
not working in the gaming industry
anymore and they don't really care about
how people gamble with their money
at the end of the day my purpose is to
go out there and build things to create
inventions and whatever else there's a
lot that needs to be done before Bitcoin
really sort of succeeds where it needs
to be a lot of the things I've been
working on such as properly scaled SPV
and whatever else all need to be
implemented and that's going to take
quite a number of years and the
technology is far more interesting than
how people sort of flip their money what
why don't you sell all your Bitcoin why
don't you sell it in cash out and do
what and I mean sell all my VidCon in
cash out so one I won't get that much
money even as an OTC trade I'd get less
and and then what you just said you have
a lot of other technology you'd want to
go create you can use that quarter of a
billion dollars to go build new
technology called building new
technology now I mean we've already got
in Chains already several hundred people
around the world we've got offices in
multiple continents we've got over a
thousand patent filings now I mean your
assumption is the selling bitcoin is
necessary but why wouldn't you I mean
wouldn't it wouldn't it is sitting on it
isn't that hurting the narrative on the
fact that this has not being used as a
currency why not move it why not put it
elsewhere
I moved Bitcoin now I spending with
Bitcoin where I can so again you're
you're thinking that if I've got money
in a bank I don't go out there every day
and see what I can spend do you make
most your purchases on Bitcoin or is it
the combination cash credit Bitcoin oh
of course not I mean if I could make
most of my purchases a Bitcoin I would
the reality here is I can't there's
actually less opportunity than there was
in 2013 2014 as the BDC price has gone
up
many people have just abandoned the
whole concept of you
in Bitcoin as a monetary system and it's
left it with the gamblers
so there's actually it's actually harder
to spend Bitcoin right now that it was
but what's the biggest commercial
company that is allowing purchases being
made by Bitcoin a very well-known
company that you can go by with Bitcoin
don't know any don't know any so if I
wanted to go into Apple Ford you know a
Walmart and Amazon
I can't make any to purchase with
Bitcoin today no and that's a problem do
you think they used to be Microsoft I
mean used to be Microsoft but we made
things too difficult elaborate if you
don't mind well people will take Bitcoin
when it's cheap and easy when you have
fees that a variable and go up and down
and and more than a cent then you don't
have an online cash system anymore very
interesting you know when you when you
did the interview with BBC Wall Street
Journal I want to say 2016 or 2017 I
don't know the exact timeline I think it
was around 2016 when you did the
interview and you know the gentleman
that's interviewing you is asking you
know why are you doing this interview I
said yeah I'm doing this interview but
that doesn't mean I have to bounce
around and TV cameras I don't want money
I don't want Fame I don't want adoration
I just want to be left alone yes and
then you said the gentleman asked you
says why now
why have you decided to identify
yourself as santoshi Nakamoto you said I
didn't decide I had people to decide
this matter for me and they're making
life difficult not for me but my friends
family and staff they want to be private
I don't want any one of them to be
impacted by this none of it is true
there are a lot of stories out there
that are made up I'm going to do this
once and once only I'm going to come in
front of camera once and I will never
ever be seen on camera ever again for
any TV station or any media ever what
changed
those people didn't stop those people
kept their
be yourself people like mr. Maxwell and
others in core have been attacking me
for years now not 2015 when they
released a whole lot of fake information
not right now they were contacted by the
tax office in Australia I had been
actually contacted them I was talking to
the tax office and of course the tax
office has decided to verify things but
instead of doing it properly they talked
to people like mr. Antonopoulos and Greg
Maxwell and things others who told them
no that's not how Bitcoin works you
can't tax Bitcoin it's all hidden
and this guy's scamming you and of
course none of those people wanted a
version of Bitcoin that was honest and
worked within the law and the tax
officers could manage so they made up
stories about me and I've been doing it
ever since and so you're coming out to
defend a position over and over again
well I didn't really even come out I
mean in December 2015 this whole fake
swatting and raid I mean I moved to the
UK here in October 2015 and then you
have these fake media things does anyone
ever ask why there happens to be a
secret raid on someone with television
cameras just waiting there I mean think
about it for a moment in an empty house
so not where I'm living not in the
country I've been living for months
where everyone knew because all my my
tax things everything were finalized
imagine that you've got camera crews
sitting outside somewhere that means
someone's told them these things
camera crews don't randomly just sit
there waiting so think about this does
that sound like it just randomly happens
like a whole lot of camera crews are
just sitting there waiting for a
group of police to run in and SWAT a
house and then stories come out about
things I mean no one seems to think
anymore they don't question things they
they just assume what they're being fed
by the media must be correct what what
was the media feeding about you as the
are you saying defeatist the media's
feeding people than you are not sat on a
wall or what is the media feeding that
was part of it
we had a lot of sort of and we still get
a lot of people wanting to discredit
what I'm doing so this whole concept is
whatever I do is bad so Satoshi would
never paint must be health any health
any of course actually had patents and
most of the guys in Corps have patents
and most of the other people who
hypocritically sit there saying no can't
be Craig because have patents just I do
it better
so then they sit there saying oh well
you copied this except you don't get a
patent by copying something and it's
easy to make the claim saying look this
is just a diffi holman process except if
you write a patent well which we do you
have to actually do this section called
prior art and in prior art you put all
the things that already exist and you
explain why you're different to them so
if you want to have a really good paint
you sit there a new document how things
really are now this is the existing
intellectual property these are the
existing inventions you know like when
you document other people's work and
other things and you basically put that
there and then you say but this is my
invention and what you actually have
patented is your invention not the
previous things but most people have
never filed a patent most people have
never done a thesis so
when people sit there and comment on
these things it's without knowledge
without understanding and it's very easy
to sit there on social media these days
and this is a part of the problem with
things like Twitter you can sit there
and say oh isn't that terrible
but you don't care about the truth you
don't care about what's real because we
have this whole culture now I'm not
doing something not actually going out
there and making a better world because
we don't need to anymore we can click
like I didn't actually have to go out
there and and help that person because I
liked video of them suffering I said
that it was really terrible I saw and I
felt and I emoted online and I said I
feel so bad and other people came back
to me and said we feel bad for you
that's our world now if we want to go
back to a biblical thing it's the Good
Samaritan
except the Good Samaritan is the one who
isn't on social media everyone else
walking along they're the ones who are
on social media the Pharisees who passed
the guy and watch him bleed but they get
back and they tweet about it and they
say he was bleeding but I'm really good
because I made sure I stayed pure if I
got blood on my hands I wouldn't be able
to go to Temple 1 on Sabbath and then
the next group come through and they sit
there and they say I'm so pure because
obviously I'm with other people and and
we could have been attacked and we want
to live in fear don't we we don't want
to do something because poor little me
but what if it's not just me what about
these people I'm with what about them
honey I know there's only probably two
attackers and there's like ten of us but
but but what if some of us get hurt so
we walk on
that's what our world is becoming we
leave the people there we sit there and
we click on people and we say isn't this
great because look what I've done I've
helped by clicking like you haven't and
all these people who think they have
you're scum and if you don't like that
get off you're freaking out us and do
something about it what what part of the
question I asked made you want to go
there
I asked you a question saying about what
the media is saying about you and then
you went to that part about the Good
Samaritan but what what made you want to
constantly come out and talk about the
fact that you're Satoshi Nakamoto who
cares what I did about you who said I
did the media this is all the media
Facebook all these other things of media
you're saying that I did I didn't come
out and say it
you said constantly I said I would do
something in go away and then no-one
goes away yeah so I didn't all these
other people put out other things and
whatever else so I didn't sit there
going this is what I'm going to do for
you I'm going to be your great leader
I'm going to lead your revolution I
didn't sit there in 2010 coming out and
going hey I'm Satoshi I want to give in
to this I didn't do it in 2017 even I
didn't want to sit there and say look I
am I was just building I was building a
working version of electronic cash that
scales we're already doing millions of
transactions at the moment building
something that works but that's what
scares people because guess what
something that where this kills off all
the little false mantras about Ponzi
schemes that make you money by doing
nothing so why am I going there because
this is there this is what people are
doing the media exists because those
people who do nothing
those people who watch those people who
voyeuristically sit there and think that
the world is going to move because they
watch TV or they watch YouTube but they
watch whatever else that's the problem
so so there are there are a few names
involved when it comes out to Satoshi
Nakamoto you're obviously one of them
you mentioned another one which is Hal
Finney who was also there early at the
beginning and then there's also another
one named the they were climbing who I
believe they've sued you for some 5.2
billion dollars are Dave's estranged
brother so dave was my friend Dave died
in 2013 in February 2018 this estate
you're right the estate of Dave climbing
initiated a lawsuit at the US District
Court for Southern District of Florida
against Wright over the rights of 5.11
eight billion dollars worth of Bitcoin
claiming that right the fraud of
climbing of bitcoins and intellectual
property rights yes except I won't go
into detail on that because it's an
ongoing case but here's the point for
you if you haven't moved it how have you
stolen it it's like saying well here's
the bar of gold that's sitting in the
safe deposit box it has never moved
you must have stolen it because I've
lost the keys you lost the keys not me
they're saying that they lost the key so
therefore you stolen so they lost the
keys to Dave's Bitcoin but they're
saying you stole it yes because it
hasn't moved but do you have the keys to
yours or you don't have access to it
because I know you also told in court
testimony last year that you also don't
have access to your Bitcoin no that's
not exactly what I say and I didn't say
that would mine I said there was a trap
first but as I said I'm not going to go
into detail about the court case it's
ongoing so so okay let's set the money
aside then it's ongoing case but let's
go back to Dave so yourself Hal and Dave
were involved at the beginning stage
with you
engines not the way you're making out
there are a few people online hell
helped in that basically I sent out code
to people and they reviewed so was he
Satoshi no but like many other people
they could have taken an active interest
it was a experimental project at that
stage and if people wanted to be
involved they could have been so have
you ever met Hal Finney not physically
no never have okay but but dave was a
friend of yours
yes that was okay then there's another
person that comes out that's Adam back
do you have a relationship with Adam
only from Twitter and other such things
so you and Adam have never met each
other not physically now I've just did
with him since 2014 online I spoke with
him over email and whatever else in 2008
but now Adams Adams not the brightest
guy in the bunch but unfortunately he's
easily too for other people to
manipulate is the best way to put it
Adams not the brightest guy of the bunch
you're saying Adam is not bright I mean
you know listen when I bring up your
name and people talk [ __ ] about you I'm
like listen you can't say Craig is not
bro you can say a lot of things about a
lot of people you can't say Craig it's
not brilliant I mean Adam got his PhD in
distributed computing systems which is a
perfect background to builder the
central computer network I mean Adams
no actually that's not that's what he
says now so Adams thing is on a type of
parallel code system that has nothing to
do with anything like Bitcoin and Adam
didn't invent proof-of-work
contrary to what he says his the system
and Bitcoin isn't the system that Adam
had mentioned and Hashcash Adam was the
only one who answered my emails at the
time the system used in Bitcoin is by
Aurora NL which
was years before atoms now they actually
had exactly analogous apart from
different Shire algorithm the same sort
of methodology of taking the number of
zeros and whatever else out on the other
hand had a proof of work system where he
matched up words and basically sold
tokens individually it was more along
the lines of Tim Mays idea of everyone
having their own money that's annal yes
but Adam doesn't admit this Adam tries
to gloss over everything and say yes i
invented that form of proof of work
could basically bitcoins just hash cash
with a couple other enhancements and and
of course so therefore it's all mine
so that's Adam okay so in 2016 Financial
Times side abacus potential Nakamoto
candidate along with Nick's Sabol and
how Finney no they didn't a contributor
so Financial Times contributor that's
basically like an advertiser so an
advertiser in financial times not staff
not a writer
so this is the problem with Forbes and
Financial Times and whatever else they
allow people to blog for money on their
sites so and they sit there calling this
like people say that Financial Times no
they didn't there's little tiny links up
the top saying contributors and things
like this
no contributors just advertisers they're
just shooing and it's
2020 a YouTube channel called barely
sociable claimed that back was Nakamoto
back and denied it Craig Wright had sued
back because back stated that right was
not Nakamoto what's right subsequently
drop into suitors that also contributor
did that happen not exactly the way it
was what actually happened was we
couldn't get hold of back to serve him I
was attempting to to sue him for
defamation not because he didn't call me
satoshi or whatever else which I didn't
care but the same day we fought we
couldn't track him down the same day
that we we gave up trying to find him
and serve Him
and filed in the court that we were
giving up wasting money running after
the world trying to get him as he hid he
got served
Saku ironically so it wasn't quite the
way they're making out so are you saying
it's not right about Adam back that he
doesn't have a PhD in distributing
computing systems it's not distributed
computing systems now it is to do with
parallel code so no it's again take a
PhD yes yes it's a computer science one
no it's not in this area
no Hashcash is not a distributed
computing system no hashcash isn't the
proof of work system used in Bitcoin so
did you get a PhD yourself income in a
computing systems or know yourself
computer science and economics okay
because then there's another thing that
was sent over to me is the fact that the
right claim to have a PhD computer
science from Charleston University on
his LinkedIn profiles of 2015 but the
university told Forbes that it was only
awarded now that the university told
nobody
Forbes didn't write anything a
contributor using Forbes this was also
canonical true this our contributor yes
have a look at the top of the thing
where it says contributor
I mean people keep saying that these
things are real they don't understand
that just because it says fools Forbes
are selling their brand down to get
money because that's what they do these
days which by the way you are right
about that son I'm giving you credit the
fact that there are contributors that
you can pay two thousand dollars or four
thousand dollars to say I'm a writer for
Forbes but it's really you can write
anything you want there's not really an
approval process so that looks terrible
yeah but then it says the university
offers that only were the two masters
degree and not a doctorate right PhD
from CSU was finally awarded February
2017 is there accuracy to this or no cuz
I know you were saying you're still
going to university one it was three
masters I had to drop one because other
people complained that I was actually
enrolled in multiple degrees which I was
the university did know about it but the
pressure on the University I dropped
that one like one and a half courses
before I was finished it the submission
of my doctorate for that one was done
earlier what I said was I had a
doctorate my doctorate the other one
which I wasn't arguing about which
people [ __ ] about because it's not
computer science was theology I also
have many other degrees at the same time
I still study not out of university yet
I was still in there I am actually
writing my thesis in law over here in
the UK at the moment so I have multiple
things you just don't know half of what
I had and I don't actually manage any of
my social media other than slack so I
can't even say what was on anything like
that I don't know I mean I don't run
LinkedIn I don't run Facebook I don't
have a Twitter account so I won't match
for anything that any of these things
say because I don't run social media I
was on Twitter for a while and that's it
sorry but by the way you're obviously
very interesting individual October 1970
I'm also an October baby what
being October were you born 23rd you're
23rd interesting October 23rd and
yourself
say that again and yourself I'm 18 I'm 5
days before you except not 70 on 78 so
we're 8 years apart you are 8 years 7
years and 51 weeks older than me to be
exact I know your numbers guy I have to
give you the exact number so we're
accurate there so going back to this
Adam back it's very interesting when I
look at this you know here's what I I
don't think this is a best friend of
yours john mcafee there's somebody you
know of john mcafee we've Joe John is a
scamming bastard and there's any no nice
thing to ever say about John I mean yeah
John John hasn't done anything good in
his life that I know of I mean he's
taking other people's coded and bloody
McAfee and scammed people out of things
there and then he's scamming people
again his whole thing is how do I make
money quickly here's one thing he did
say by the we've had John McAfee on when
we went to his place and it's a very
interesting interview it's very very
it's the only time where somebody
knocked on a door and one of his guys
ran to the door with a gun in his hand
which is quite unique we've never had
that before in the middle of an
interview here's what he did say when a
guy asked him who is Satoshi Nakamoto he
said in satoshis white paper every ward
that has dual spellings for American and
British English is British every
sentence is followed by two spaces there
are only two of the cues that are
British and only one of those two has
two spaces and every single of his
papers run some authoring software which
he's alluding to back in uh Satoshi
Nakamoto I mean that theory cuz you're
from Australia he's from UK you know
he's from Britain so there's a little
bit of that when you look at the data on
how he wrote code what how it could go
back to being him what are your thoughts
on that number one I write with double
spaced or single spaced depending on
what I'm publishing I write in English
UK English or
American English depending on where
writing I am writing with some US
universities at the moment and when I do
that I produce in APA 7 at the moment
and that is different to the standard I
use when I'm writing here at Leicester
and Leicester is a British university so
that because it's a law degree requires
different things so I write basically on
what I have to write so when I'm
publishing in a certain type of paper I
published a certain way now my choice
would would have been Australian English
at the beginning which is basically
British English with a few extra words
but Tim in 2008 I was completing my
masters at law at Northumbria in the UK
and so most of how I wrote was how I
would write when I'm doing law sometimes
for accounting purposes interesting
interesting to know that when you when
you're sharing that but again that was
that perspective and then I'll give you
this last one you know we'll go into
speed round is here's about Adam back so
you know Adam has no clue about Bitcoin
I mean you can waste all the time you
want going Adam back has this that and
the other Adam back doesn't have a clue
about how Bitcoin works he has no idea
about the economics of the system the
legality of the system he doesn't have
an idea how any of it works and
basically he didn't even realize that
the proof of work system in Bitcoin
isn't like his so if he was such an
expert in it why didn't he actually pick
up on the differences so sorry now he's
not doing it behind he really doesn't
even understand the basics of Bitcoin
yet he doesn't even understand the
basics of Bitcoin that's that's us
that's a pretty strong statement to say
that that's been really nice this is
camera really like you're going there
without him back to say he has no clue
what he's doing he comes out to Bitcoin
Adam came into this in 2013 and
basically the whole thing was I got
mentioned on the white paper I my
wonderful and that's all he's ever done
and he does whatever the hell gets him
likes Adam doesn't care about actually
creating anything a Bitcoin building
anything he hasn't Adam cares the people
like what he says now that short term
might work but long term you don't get
anything out of it so imagine if you
were Thomas Edison you can actually try
and make a better light bulb like trying
thousands of experiments and doing
things and not being liked or you can
sit there and say how wonderful you are
and for a little while people will
remember you and they'll say wow isn't
that great he looks good
what wonderful flim-flam except guess
what you don't build anything they
haven't built anything nothing
yes I the some some people may say he's
Nikola Tesla and you're trying to be
Edison which is Nikola is the one that
came up with the idea but Edison took
credit for well actually that's actually
wrong too I know what people love to say
when recently Wikipedia era Edison
wasn't necessarily what you would call
it nice guy in any sense of the word but
Tesla wasn't the one who came up with
things Tesla was a very good media man
what Tesla did was every single day he
did little shows he did things with like
showing electricity between basically
two electrodes and sparks and and the
media loved him he was a showman and he
worked with other people and he got his
name on a lot of patents with other
people some of which ended up suing him
so he wasn't dumb he wasn't but he's
nowhere near this person the people are
making him out to be now but there's
value in creating this mythology about
this show man and more than anything
else he was a showman
so you relate more to the the asphalt
Edison and a nice showman Nikola Tesla
unfortunately yes I work I work I get up
in the morning I work I spend my day
working I study so I mean most people
don't realize what it is to really work
at the moment I'm not doing a PhD I'm
doing a PhD and multiple other degrees
simultaneously full-time and I'm not
gonna say what they will laugh because
I'll have people [ __ ] going you're
doing X Squared's in that's not right
and then pressuring the unis who already
know that I've done some of these things
in the past and that I've told but yeah
it's just easier not to have to respond
so not gonna say it's easier not to have
to respond at the end of the day I'm not
going to get any employment
opportunities or anything like that ever
again because of qualifications or any I
do this for me I don't do it because I
mean I've got
twenty-something degrees now and that's
actually a negative if you think about
it if you actually put that out there no
one hires me because I have sort of
qualifications in our history and music
and computer science
no one cares they actually see that as a
negative but I see it as a positive
because for instance just yesterday we I
put in a white paper to go to to be
filed as a patent based on some of the
things I've been doing in an our history
degree which I'm not going to say
because Payton hasn't been filed yet but
it's to do with certain types of ancient
painting techniques and whatever else
and how Sotheby's and others can
actually manage and maintain records of
of artwork so the reality is by having a
diverse mix of knowledge actually find
out more things that I could actually do
so yeah it's it's it's very interesting
to only see this topic of satoshi
nakamoto it's soul everybody is wanting
to find out who it really is some are
saying you so much saying other people I
think many people in the community yes
people run around saying all these
things not wanting to be me but the
reality is if you don't really if I'm
not going to make money doing the thing
selling myself and prostituting myself
into conferences if I don't take money
to present if I'm not doing any of that
what's it matter I mean when I file a
patent when I create something when I
write papers it's all peer-reviewed so
when I have a patent application I don't
go hey I'm so Tasha give me a patent it
goes before examiner's and those
examiner's have no idea who I am and
that's a good thing this is why it
doesn't matter no one
tears I mean when I create when the
company creates when we all sit there
when we build things and whatever else
and we sell code that's plumbing most
people don't know they don't care it
works best that way I I mean I actually
like being plumbing I like the other eye
I have Asperger's and I find face to
face conversations with people difficult
I find interacting with people difficult
that's why most of my degrees have been
distance and now online for most of my
life why I do these things why I sort of
have unusual work habits and all the
rest because at the end of the day it's
just it sort of fits with what I am and
this concept of I'm going to go out
there and and run round and be eccentric
an have everyone love me I don't really
care I don't want that I'm happiest
because I built things and here's the
thing that everyone can sit there and
throw [ __ ] at me all you want in five
years time I'm likely to have my name on
maybe three four thousand patents and
I'll still be patenting the technologies
needed to make any blockchain work well
no one wanted to listen to me
so as you see them come out as we show
how do we scale to millions and billions
of transactions a second then too bad
that's all I have to say I mean if you
think that I need to have your
approbation that I need your love and
your basically worship then you're
insane I've had
executive on my team what ass burgers
that I work with and we we one day we're
sittin on having a conversation together
and the topic of Bill Gates came up
because Bill Gates also has been claimed
to have have a spur and there's been a
lot of people by the way lots of
successful people what what why do you
think there's a link between Asperger's
and a genius meaning they're able to do
things and process issues in ways that
the average person can't what is it I've
heard a lot of different theories I'm
curious to know what you say about it I
think there are a couple different areas
one we don't have the same level of
distraction and some other people I
hyper focus on tasks which actually
annoys many people I know because you
just get into something and they try and
talk to you in a tower huh they say the
house is burning down uh-huh
someone's running off with the children
I mean but true you're into it you're
it's there and you find something that
you obsess about and not many other
people would have done Bitcoin because
they didn't obsess everyone gave up on
Bitcoin as a concept back in about 2001
that's when everything really started
falling apart 2003 everything was dead
in cryptocurrency space everyone told me
how stupid I was by actually still
thinking about how we do online payments
and how you do these things lots of
problems lots of people wanted to pull
funding from me and all sorts of things
in the past because it's not solvable
it's not worth it
find something else and I kept obsessing
and everyone else is out there going off
and finding other things and I kept
obsessing I tried this I tried that and
that's the whole thing so you get
certain types of people who if their
focus is on something that needs to be
solved we'll just put everything into it
until they solve it
I had a older guy that I knew in
Australia who well ended up actually
doing quite well when he was about 80
but he he grew orchids and he obsessed
over them and he spent like 50 years
breeding and doing orchids and
everything like that and now these days
suddenly orchids are being sold
everywhere and he has rights to a number
of things that he sold and everyone
thought I mean 50 years worth of what
everyone thought was wasting time money
effort and all the rest and now that
he's eight he is suddenly getting money
which is unfortunate because he's that
old and but it helps his family still
but that's the point
if you had someone who obsesses that way
that will try things
I mean Edison didn't invent the light
bulb people get that wrong arc lighting
existed filament lighting existed but it
didn't work because it would burn out
after like an hour and having a light
bulb you change every hour yeah no one
wants to change light bulbs every hour
so he sat there basically experimenting
with every material every way he could
do it until he had one that lasted days
and then longer and longer and longer
and the sort of obsession that I have
for knowledge for other things not many
people it's I mean one way of putting it
would be it's a form of insanity and a
lot of people like myself have this form
of insanity but it's a socially
acceptable form of insanity so I will
sit there and I will digest knowledge I
will read and learn and everything I can
and that's how I'm happiest I mean
people don't really get this I think my
wife has accepted it but she doesn't
understand it but like we were
a few years ago on a yacht in the
Mediterranean and the kids and
everything having fun doing the whole
fall off the back into the nice blue
water bit and all the rest and I'm
sitting up there on the top writing and
working I can see that but you said two
things so one was when it comes out two
distractions you're you're able to stay
hyper focus on tasks of people say yeah
yeah yeah what was this is the second
one that there's not that much emotions
where you're not offended as much as
another person is know that in a
different way people think that myself
and a lot of others don't feel that we
don't have mote we don't show it so and
we don't react so my wife looks at me
strangely because I don't react to pain
in the normal way something happens and
I have an injury and she said say go
isn't that really painful that I go yes
it is incredibly painful honey and she
go but you don't look like you're in
pain no and I am so that causes people
sort of it doesn't match up right agent
so I mean I've done lots of absolutely
think I used to run a farm and if you
want to NGO so I actually still don't if
I'm I just never get back to Australia
but if you want to injure yourself a lot
have a ranch between fencing with barbed
wire and heavy equipment and tractors
and everything like that injuries the
law so that was interesting very good
feedback there's sensitivity for me from
working with Asperger's they're
extremely sensitive to the point where
they will do whatever they can to prove
you wrong of going out there and doing
their research to say I told you I was
right there's a different cannabis would
you agree with that a little bit of that
going on
am ia pedantic [ __ ] and
[ __ ] has to be the word too pedantic
yes I actually had an argument with my
psychologist who was discussing the the
the concept of like the word weird
because I was saying I didn't like the
use of the work weird and one of the
quizzes he'd given me because and the
word weird actually is used Adil Iran I
mean when you talk about the weird
sisters in Shakespeare in Macbeth the
three sisters it it's the fate so weird
actually is the fates the control the if
you you think about the the concept from
Greek and and then Roman sort of copy of
what we see as mythology as fates and
how they control our lives that's what
we it is we just use it wrong so I get
into the etymology of words which I find
interesting and yeah not many people
want to be told that they're saying
things that are correct rather what can
old were you when you realize you had
Asperger's how old were you did somebody
say it to you did you go to the doctor
how old were you I know I had diagnosed
my mother had me in front of
psychologists when I was in high school
and then they sort of I ended up going
to a Catholic school I got taken out of
a state school to put into a Catholic
school and the rector's and everything
like that dealt with me and treated me a
little bit differently because of it so
that was actually a good move
interesting but interesting so high
school were you were you two cool guy in
high school were you know like the 4.0
genius getting everything right or
pushing the teachers challenging the
teachers who were you in high school now
I was he annoying prick I was the guy
who nearly got expelled because I had a
big
once with the teacher I was a textbook
and then demonstrated how the textbook
was wrong and we shouldn't be teaching
this crap and yeah somehow I see that I
don't know yeah I didn't have a good I
didn't let it go very well so I think
they said sit down crack know but it's
actually wrong when you just learn it no
well listen thank you for being
transparent and being willing to talk
about this that was very helpful because
I do know in the business environment
there's a lot of folks that are working
with somebody that has it and they don't
have an understanding of it and
sometimes parents have kids that have
that in its template or somewhere that I
know it's tough for the kid because the
kid wishes parents knew listen man I
don't know what I have but I'm a little
bit different please be patient with me
this isn't how I made myself be like
this I was born like this so that's the
problem we have a educational system now
that for the most part just tries to
slot people in and do exams and it's not
good I mean education isn't about
training in exams it's about making
people think and be part of society and
understand and and kids now actually
look at all these other courses like
music and in English and and sit there
ago but why do I need this that's not
what I'm going to get into uni with it's
not where my grades are coming from
well because it's education you don't
want just to get a tick box you want to
learn to think yeah I'm with you there
speed run I'm gonna give you a name tell
me the first word that comes to mind
I'll give you a name just tell me the
first word that comes to mind Gavin
Andresen very interesting guy and he got
too much [ __ ]
Jeff Garrick yeah well anyway Gregory
Maxwell
Trotsky Trotsky okay keep Peter Wolf on
blood stream
oh don't waste my time
okay fair enough Dan Kaminsky an idiot
that has had run-ins with me since 2000
or so that tries to pretend he doesn't
and forgets that I still got papers out
there on DNS and things like that but
I'm not the best person to point out
when things are wrong and a lot of
people get annoyed when I do especially
in conferences and things like that like
when you sit there and go actually your
mathematics is wrong your this process
is wrong you haven't used the right
statistic and I do that to people in
conferences when they're presenting
things and I don't endear people but I'm
not actually meaning to be a complete
[ __ ]
it's just when I see things that I want
to go into detail it's for me it's not
actually to be a complete prick it's
just the way I am Jack Dorsey no I'm
sorry you did not spend an hour in your
sauna and a hundred and ten degrees stop
bullshitting
fair enough how funny
a shame that we don't put more money
into research into certain medical
problems
Vitalik material just admit it you
thought oh wow okay people [ __ ] don't
care Max Keiser
really find something better the shield
[Laughter]
magistrate judge Bruce Reinhardt I'm not
gonna make any comments about ongoing
case stuff whatever else John
trophy I didn't you did say stuff about
him earlier the other john mcafee get
off the drugs Ron Paul don't actually
know I feel some interesting ideas but
but yeah I think you'd like he's an
interesting guy
jamie dimon part of the problem
Mark Zuckerberg there are solutions to
digital cash you don't need to make it
yourself just use Bitcoin Michael burry
that now enough don't no no David David
Solomon know who it is but I don't
really know enough okay and last but not
least Satoshi nakamoto's I shouldn't
have abdicated you know I got at I said
this to you earlier the more I talked to
you I saw two different people if Edward
Norton and Charlie Sheen were to make a
baby together he will look like Craig
Wright look like you Ed Norton i fishing
I don't even want to imagine that I
really don't want to see Charlie Sheen
amid normal making a baby
I mean it's there's no I mean I Jimmy
who I work with is gay and I've got lots
of gay friends so that's not the issue I
just those two together just doesn't do
it for me I'm sorry maybe in a future
movie coming soon you know it's it's
what's gonna be happening but the wait
when you talk you have angles you look
like Norton there's angles you talk to
look like Charlie Sheen Craig right what
I can tell you is I appreciate you for
being a guest somebody came in and
taking all my questions that you were
very classy about some of the topics I
brought up I know some of the topics
were pretty directed and pointed but you
took a will and we've had a good time to
get here for the last hour and a half
hour and 45 minutes again thank you for
your time for being a guest on May 18
you're welcome I must say your sort of
picture in the background interesting
mix of people there yes I mean I can
pick out most of them I mean Lincoln's
easy
I mean Friedman Einstein Kennedy etc I'm
not quite sure here the guy with all the
medals is happens to be I mean he could
be several people and which dictator
that's the question he looks like
several
Iran the former Shah of Iran well he's
the Shah of Iran and then you got Martin
Luther King then you got a hip-hop
artist I'm sure you listen to a lot of
his music Tupac I I've got children so I
don't have a choice you know over here
and I think what you'll appreciate is
they're sitting in a bank vault and
they're debating two books see if you
recognize these two books one has a
little dragon that looks like a Bitcoin
II hot one I'm sure what the other book
is it could be it could be looks like
Rothbart or something by the cover but
it's thick enough to be Roth bad and the
colors right for a rough parts book good
clothes in there debating Communist
Manifesto on Atlas Shrugged is what
they're debating while I'm grant and
Karl Marx had different philosophies and
obviously it's politicians they're
debating those two topics although yeah
the Communist Manifesto is even thinner
than that by the way yeah you're right
it is I got to contact the painter and
say why did you pay an additional 80
pages to it exactly yes honestly like
how do you know that's Marcus Aurelius
it is Marcus Aurelius yes
Aristotle hmm I try and be a little bit
stoic really fouled but I would like to
be a good stoic of just doesn't work I
keep trying and to go into the whole
aristotle bit you can't actually say
someone is happy until the day they die
because you never know what will happen
tomorrow so
similarly I'm going to say I can't say
that I'm not a stoic until the day I die
so until then I'm gonna keep trying it's
not an easy thing to do that's for sure
very harshly in this world yes
especially in this world no doubt about
it
Craig thank you thank you for your time
so I got to tell you many of you asked
me to do this interview even though you
don't like him I posted something on
Twitter saying I just sat down with
Craig right and I can't tell you most
people said I cannot believe you sat
down with them he's a con artist he's a
scammer he's a liar there's no way he's
satoshi nakamoto and then the people
that believe he is then I'm posted on
Twitter they DM me and say said he is
here's why don't listen to everybody
else so what are your thoughts is he
Satoshi Nakamoto the founder of Bitcoin
is it somebody else what do you think
about the argument would Adam back or
whether it's if any all of these things
I'm curious comment below on who you
think is such a she Nakamoto and if you
enjoy today's interview have two other
ones I want you to watch one of them is
with John McAfee I did this interview a
couple years ago in his house in
Tennessee and if you've not seen this
interview it's epic in the middle of it
somebody knocks on the door one of his
guys pulls out a gun John had a gun the
entire time while I did the interview
and it was a different kind of a
conversation but we did talk about
Bitcoin and the other interview to a
Peter Schiff who is that's not the
biggest Pro Bitcoin he's anti Bitcoin
he's more Pro gold and if you've not
watched I won't click over here and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
you
[Music]